Audiences around the world have
been thrilled by the new Avatar
movie — but why was one of its stars
terrified of returning to Pandora?
In 2009, Zoe Saldaña appeared in two movies that
would later become the basis for new franchises:
J.J. Abrams' Star Trek and James Cameron's
Avatar. Her role as Uhura spanned three movies,
and with the release of 2022's
Avatar: The Way of Water,
the actress will now settle into multiple
appearances as Na'vi princess Neytiri.
Of course, Saldaña is also a long-running
player in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
with her role as Gamora, a member of
the Guardians of the Galaxy. Clearly,
playing a character in a feature film
series is nothing new to Saldaña,
but Neytiri in particular is the one
part that took time to return to her.
"I see you."
Many public reactions to Avatar: The
Way of Water are confirming that the
13-year wait between movies has more
than paid off. This marks the longest
gap between franchise character appearances
for Zoe Saldaña, who filmed all the sequels
to Star Trek and Gamora's MCU spots
within a few years of one another.
In a press conference during the
promotion of the Avatar sequel,
the actress spoke candidly about the
strong emotional connections she shares
with her Na'vi counterpart. Saldaña
described playing Neytiri again as:
"Terrifying… When something is very
similar to you, you can’t see it,
it’s just so close to you that it’s
not in front of you. Neytiri and I
have lived parallel lives. There’s a level
of fearlessness and rebellion that I have
as a person that Neytiri had as herself,
and we were able to find kindred in that."
In an interview with Deadline, Saldaña reiterated
some of the talking points she had shared earlier
and discussed the unique experience of being
a misfit while growing up — an experience that
unlocked plenty of bold creative potential
as an adult. She also explained that she can
see these qualities in the directors she
has worked with, including James Cameron.
Parenthood, in particular, plays a big
role in the new Avatar movie. Jake and
Neytiri have three biological children
and one adopted daughter in Kiri. Love
and fear are two major emotions that come
with parenthood, which Saldaña related to
her own experiences with motherhood. At the
Way of Water press conference, she said:
"In my personal life, when I became a
parent, fear entered my realm. The fear
of losing someone that you love
so much [...] You spend a great
amount of your time creating hypothetical
scenarios that are just unimaginable."
This isn't the first time the actor
has elaborated on these feelings,
either. In 2019, she told People magazine:
"As a working mom, you live with
that conflict of having to go to
work and wanting to go to work but also
wanting to always be with your children."
Clearly, Saldaña's understanding of Neytiri's
powerful spirit and empathy fit comfortably
with the moving themes in the Avatar films — and
it will serve her well in the movies to come.